they've confirmed that 4934 people have
sadly lost their lives to this disease
now that is an increase of 621 from
yesterday it's just important to caveat
that these are people who died in
hospital there there isn't yet a way of
including those people who may have died
from home so they may be a fractional
underestimate but these are the people
who have lost their lives in hospital
4934 up by 621 now it's important to say
that very sadly you know for the last
number of days we've been sitting here
saying that's the highest jump since
this crisis began actually today that is
not the highest jump since the crisis
began 621 yesterday the daily death jump
was 708 so that is slightly down and and
we've been talking all morning and
across the week as well about the
importance of looking at the the rate of
increase so the speed at which those
numbers are rising because that give us
up gives us some insight into that curve
that politicians and experts keep
talking about flattening the curve and
it's it's very important not to forget
that this is still a huge number of
people who have died and it's still a
very very big jump indeed 621
individuals and individual families
we're talking about here but the
percentage increase on the figure
yesterday is is 14 percent